last year for me obviously we just lost
Tom Father's Day I just couldn't
actually even think about
um but this year I was like I want to
celebrate him and for the kids to
celebrate him so I planned a charity
football match and yeah it's just
exceeded my expectations completely
we've got Harry jard from McFly we've
got Ryan Thomas and we've got Ben Cohen
we've got lots and lots of stars some
love Island Stars some tick tockers
um but yeah it's going to be an amazing
day and it's going to be a really like
family fun day as well it's been really
really tough for us
um but then we've had happy we're gonna
have happy moments like this to
celebrate Tom take each day as it comes
because grief is a roller coaster and
you know you're not just gonna ever wake
up one thing go oh I'm okay because
that's that's just not life is it